hey what is up everybody it's anna mack
here for anime outbroad and it is
finally time to dive into the absolute
chaos of trying to figure out the
identity of luffy's mother i mean there
is so little information about monkey d
mommy that probably the most popular
theory out there is the meme theory that
luffy's mom is actually gender bend
crocodile but along with the various
options i want to explore i do have my
own favorite theory about who luffy's
mother might be a theory that involves
god valley forbidden love roger's
execution and the real reason why dragon
wants to destroy the entire world noble
system so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our videos
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
but very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar okay so when i was first getting
caught up to one piece through the
one-piece virgin podcast my co-host kept
telling me to pay attention to crocodile
because he might actually have some
crazy secret connection to luffy then
after i got to impel down they revealed
the croco mom theory the idea that
crocodile is actually a woman who was
turned into a man with ivankov's
horuhoru
that is the secret weakness that ivankov
used to blackmail crocodile in chapter
540. crocodile used to be a woman and
not only that but he is literally
luffy's mother and yes when i first
heard this theory i thought everyone was
just messing with me because i still
wasn't caught up but no this is actually
a real theory although i feel like most
people just treat it as a meme i mean i
think they do with one piece fans it can
be hard to tell when we're memeing and
when we're being serious anyway i won't
go too deeply into this theory because
it is a massive rabbit hole of pure
craziness all the evidence and counter
evidence aside to me croco mom just
doesn't make sense anymore from a
narrative perspective if such a major
reveal was going to be made about
crocodile it would have been done in the
arcs where he was relevant such as in
alabasta or impel down i don't think
that oda is going to take us all the way
to like laugh tale where so much new
stuff is going on only to randomly
reveal that oh yeah remember crocodile
that is luffy's mother i mean you can't
rule anything out with oda like i don't
think any of us were expecting gear 5 to
be looney tunes luffy but this is my
opinion at least for the time being in
terms of other crazy luffy's mom
theories unfortunately ivankov's
horuhoro nomi continues to create
absolute pandemonium among the fandom
i've heard people argue everything from
female ivankov being luffy's mother
which doesn't make sense based on
dragon's own conversations with eva to
dragon actually being luffy's mother yes
luffy's father is actually luffy's
mother but she uses iva's devil fruit to
hide her true identity in order to avoid
capture despite being the world's most
wanted criminal i mean not gonna lie
that would be a pretty awesome strategy
to stay hidden from the world government
but then that would still leave us with
the question of who is luffy's father so
let's just move on from this okay let's
just do a few quick google searches of
monkey d dragon gender bend fan art and
then let's move on from this another
major candidate for luffy's mother was
bello betty who has proximity to dragon
since she is a revolutionary herself and
her power of rallying support from
people is similar to the innate ability
that luffy seems to possess which is
inspiring people to believe in him and
to support him however bello betty's
current age is 34 which would have only
made her 15 when luffy was born and the
dragon was like 36 at the time so yeah
let's all agree to never mention this
theory again
jewelry bonnie is another popular
candidate and even though she appears to
be in her mid-20s her devil fruit allows
her to alter her own age and the age of
others
so she could technically be old enough
to be luffy's mom but she's just pulling
atsunade and making herself look younger
there are definitely some similarities
between her and luffy for instance she
can consume insane amounts of food just
like luffy and she has moments in which
her behavior and expressions are
reminiscent of luffy's the single most
interesting thing about bonnie's
backstory is found in chapter 595
of the manga after entering the new
world bonnie and her crew are defeated
by blackbeard and she is taken hostage
blackbeard says that she's too weak to
join his crew but he would allow her to
join if she agreed to become his woman
bonnie rejects this and kicks blackbeard
in the face and in that very moment the
blackbeard pirates are informed that
akainu himself is about to arrive on the
island the blackbeard pirates clear out
and leave bonnie in chains when akainu
arrives at the scene he says the
following directly to bonnie a cold
shiver ran through me when i heard you'd
run away from the government but it's
all over now on angry bonnie responds
with you you'll pay for this the marines
then take bonnie into custody but she
eventually manages to escape that part
about akainu being worried when he heard
that bonnie escaped from the world
government is definitely going to be
important later and it is clear that
there is more to bonnie than meets the
eye could she be someone who was part of
the world government but betrayed them
in order to become a pirate
was she a marine was she somehow related
to a kainu personally or was she perhaps
a world noble who decided to leave
marijua kind of like the doki hote
family bonnie is said to be from the
south blue but like her age that could
be part of a fake identity she is using
to evade the world government the
mystery of bonnie and her true
intentions get even more interesting
during the reverie even though she is
supposed to be on the run from the world
government bonnie decides to infiltrate
marijuana by posing as the elderly queen
dowager of the sorbet kingdom the sorbet
kingdom is one of the participants in
the reverie and it was once ruled by
bartholomew kuma who as we all know
ended up joining the revolutionaries at
least he did it first although he later
decided to become a warlord and
eventually he became a cyborg thanks to
dr vegapunk we don't know why kuma left
the revolutionaries and it's extremely
likely that he was forced to do it
through some sort of blackmail
after bonnie manages to sneak into the
so-called domain of the gods she sees
rosward abusing cyborg kuma who has now
become a slave for rent
this site seems to really affect and
upset bonnie which might indicate that
she has some sort of connection to kuma
and by extension to the revolutionaries
and if bonnie is in fact connected to
the revolutionaries then she could have
met dragon and conceived luffy with him
again provided that she is actually a
lot older than she pretends to be other
aspects of bonnie's behavior that appear
to hint that something like this is
possible is the fact that she actually
cried during ace's execution she also
praised luffy-in-law's actions and said
she was proud to be a member of the same
generation as them and of course she
went out of her way to stop zorro from
hitting charles at sabaodi and if she
hadn't done that then zoro and the whole
archipelago would have faced massive
retaliation from the world government i
mean none of these things prove that she
is luffy's mother not even close but
they do contribute to it being a
possibility and if luffy's mother does
turn out to be someone we've already met
in the story i do think that it will be
bonnie after all her character is based
on probably the most famous female
pirate of all time
and bonnie since there are very few
female pirates in recorded history if
luffy's mother was to be a pirate then
basing her on ann bonnie would make a
lot of sense
that said it is entirely possible that
luffy's mother is a character that we
haven't even met yet a lot of people
believe that she might just be dead
we've never met her because she died
long before the story began but if she
was dead why not just say that from the
beginning if oda just made it clear that
luffy's mom died before the story
started then no one would have any more
questions about her and the story would
proceed in the same way it has with
practically no differences the fact that
oda has left this open-ended for so long
suggests that he does plan to use
luffy's mom in the story at some point
in the future and in fact in the past
oda has implied that luffy's mom is
alive and that he has already drawn her
there is some debate about whether oda
was referring to luffy's biological
mother here or if he was referring to
his adoptive mother dad but my personal
guess is that luffy's mother is still
alive and that she will be officially
introduced at some point in the future
and that brings me to my favorite theory
about the identity of luffy's mother the
theory that she is actually a member of
the celestial dragons although it might
sound crazy at first this would actually
explain a whole lot about monkey d
dragon and about where luffy's mother
has been all this time this would also
allow for luffy's mom to be introduced
late in the story and still have a lot
of narrative power and meaning to be
clear i'm not the first person to come
up with this theory and in fact taking
101 talked about it in a video over
three years ago i'm sure that even
before that this theory was being
discussed on reddit and other message
boards but what really got me thinking
about this theory is the infamous god
valley incident something i was
researching for my video about joy boy
potentially being the ancient weapon
uranus i think that god valley provides
the missing link that can tie the entire
theory together just a quick reminder
the god valley incident was a major
event that took place 38 years ago and
the truth about what happened was
strictly censored by the world
government today only the older
generations of marines are even aware of
the incident in which rox de zebic who
is probably the greatest rival of gold d
roger had assembled an incredibly
powerful pirate crew that consisted of a
young whitebeard kaido and big mom among
many other well-known pirates and then
declared war on the world government
zebek set out to make himself the king
of the world which means that he was
determined to straight up overthrow the
celestial dragons so 38 years ago zebek
and his overpowered crew attacked a
remote island known as god valley in
chapter 957 sengoku gives us a quick
overview of what happened and that is
when we learned that at the time of
zebek's attack celestial dragons were
present on the island sengoku doesn't
specify how many celestial dragons were
there or which ones we just know that
some of them were on the island along
with their slaves in order to defeat
zebec and protect the celestial dragons
the world government did something
unprecedented they worked together with
goldie roger in order to take zebic down
garp and roger were the mvps of this
fight and after zebek was defeated the
rock's pirates were dissolved the truth
about the entire incident was then
erased from history by the world
government and the island of god valley
itself vanished from the face of the
earth so we have garp roger zebek kaido
big mom and white beard all on the same
island along with a bunch of celestial
dragons what an absolutely incredible
setup for a flashback arc or even a
future one-piece movie but what if there
was one other major character present at
god valley we're just not aware of it
yet we know that garp always wanted his
son and grandson to follow in his
footsteps and to become marines
so what if a young dragon was actually
there with garp at the time of the god
valley incident dragon would have been
about 17 years old back then and he may
have been a new recruit or a marine in
training under the direct supervision of
his father garp in their capacity as
marines garp and dragon would have been
tasked with rescuing the celestial
dragons before zebek got to them dragon
may have taken part in the rescue
operation which would help explain why
garp fought so hard to protect the
celestial dragons even though he hates
them and why he was willing to work
together with roger even though he hates
pirates if dragon was present on the
island then his safety would also depend
on defeating zebic so garp did what he
had to do not just to protect the world
nobles but also to protect his own son
now if dragon was on god valley then he
likely would have had direct contact
with the celestial dragons as part of
the rescue operation and what if one of
those celestial dragons was a young
woman around the same age as dragon they
could have met there and established a
relationship that would last for many
years to come it's possible that they
ran away together right then and there
causing dragon to abandon his career as
a marine or they could have parted ways
at god valley but found some way of
staying in touch and meeting in secret
luffy was born 19 years after the god
valley incident so if luffy's brother is
a world noble who met dragon on that day
then she must have spent nearly two
decades in a relationship with him
perhaps it was a long-distance
relationship or perhaps they actually
ran away together but either way luffy
would eventually be born luffy's mother
would disappear without a trace and
dragon would become the commander of a
revolutionary army that is trying to
bring down the entire world government
so assuming that luffy's mom is a
celestial dragon who had an affair with
monkey d dragon i guess we would call
that ship dragon x dragon or double
dragon and assuming that luffy's mother
is indeed still alive then where is she
now why haven't we seen her in the story
either with luffy or with dragon or with
anyone else for the answer to these
questions we have to remember who the
celestial dragons are and how they view
other people they claim to possess the
blood of this world's creators and they
see themselves as gods compared to other
people they believe themselves to be
inherently superior to everyone else and
even the kings and nobles of powerful
kingdoms that are part of the world
government are seen as mere playthings
by the celestial dragons a single
celestial dragon has immense power the
admirals are under their direct command
and an attack of any kind on a single
world noble could lead to the
destruction of an entire kingdom
ironically these same facts provide the
explanation for both how luffy's parents
might have been able to maintain a
forbidden relationship and what could
have happened to luffy's mother after
luffy was born as i said even a single
celestial dragon has a lot of power and
influence so it is possible that luffy's
mom could have used that power to
maintain a secret relationship with
dragon there are some small hints that
something like this could have been
going on for years for instance dragon
was present at goldie rogers execution
and if you pause the anime at just the
right time you can just barely make out
what appears to be a celestial dragon in
the crowd the fact that this person is
standing among the crowd suggests that
they were there in an unofficial
capacity now to me this looks like a
male celestial dragon although it's hard
to make out the person's facial features
but even if this is a guy this world
noble could have been sent here by
luffy's mother in order to send a
message to dragon or receive a message
from him or both and yes i do realize
that this is a huge stretch but i just
found it so interesting that a celestial
dragon seems to be there at the
execution and yet you really have to go
out of your way to spot it anyway there
is a big difference between a celestial
dragon carrying on a forbidden affair
with someone and the celestial dragon
actually having a child with someone who
is not a world noble not to mention that
dragon is a member of the d clan who are
the natural enemies of the world nobles
don't forget that the world nobles are
descendants of only 19 families and that
they view their blood as sacred and pure
it goes without saying that a celestial
dragon having a child with someone who
is not a world noble would be strictly
forbidden a world noble having a child
with monkey d dragon would not only lead
to that individual woman facing social
pressure
it would actually be a lot more serious
than that a world noble having a child
with someone like dragon would challenge
the entire world noble system it would
challenge the very notion that celestial
dragons are gods who are superior to
other people and so the world nobles
would go to any length to erase all
evidence of something like that
happening if luffy's mother is a
celestial dragon the reason we've never
seen her is because she was likely
imprisoned in marijua as soon as the
truth about her son came out using her
power as a world noble she may have been
able to find ways of seeing dragon
before this and she may have even been
plotting to change the corrupt system of
the world nobles along with dragon but
as soon as a child was brought into the
picture there would be no more lenience
she would have been stripped of all of
her rights and freedoms and permanently
imprisoned somewhere deep within marijua
so that she could never reveal the fact
that a celestial dragon had a child with
someone who is not only a commoner but
also a member of the dreaded d clan on
top of that the world nobles would have
almost certainly wanted to get rid of
baby luffy permanently but it seems that
garp somehow managed to protect him
after the love of his life was
imprisoned dragon escalated his
revolutionary activities against the
world government his motivations are not
only justice and fairness his
motivations are also personal because he
wants to rescue luffy's mother from her
captivity and this is why dragon became
known as the world's worst criminal many
criminals and pirates have directly
threatened the world government over the
years but only the man who dared to have
a child with a celestial dragon deserves
the title of the very worst criminal
this is the secret that dragon has been
keeping from everyone including his own
revolutionary comrades the secret that
he fell in love with a celestial dragon
and that he is driven in part by the
desire to rescue her also it would be
pretty poetic if luffy ended up being
the one who takes down the celestial
dragons and the world government that
would prove that the d-clan really are
the natural enemies of the celestial
dragons because a single celestial
dragon's decision to have a child with a
member of the d-clan brought about the
destruction of all of them all of this
is highly speculative of course because
when it comes to luffy's mother
speculation is really all we have that
said the jewelry bonnie theory that i
mentioned earlier could actually be
somewhat combined with this theory if
bonnie is hiding her true age and if the
reason why the world government is after
her is the fact that she is a celestial
dragon who went rogue then bonnie could
be dragon's forbidden love the only
difference would be that after she was
imprisoned for having luffy she actually
managed to escape her captivity i'm not
saying this is likely but as i mentioned
earlier luffy and bonnie do have similar
energy let me know what you guys think
who is luffy's mother is she someone
we've already met in the story or is she
yet to be introduced is she dead or is
she still alive is she an important
person like a celestial dragon or is she
just a regular woman definitely leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
i always love hearing from you if you
guys enjoyed this video and you want to
see more in the future don't forget to
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free but important way of
directly supporting the channel you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys